aux etats unis à présent la tacc du
capitole du 6 janvier dernier reste un
sujet sensible on le sait la volonté de
faire la lumière sur cet assaut
meurtrier demeure toujours aussi forte
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
pourquoi thomas à quoi va servir donc
cette commission
mais c'est une commission spéciale qui a
été créée donc par la chambre des
représentants et sa mission je vous l'aï
dit enquêter rapporter les faits les
circonstances et les causes liées à l'
attaque de terrorisme intérieur du 6
janvier dernier voilà qui donne le ton
de ce à quoi il faut s'attendre pour
cette commission les démocrates veulent
en réalité tout décortiquer et plus
particulièrement les causes de cette
attaque contre le capitole ils vont
évidemment revenir sur le déroulé des
faits de cette journée du 6 janvier mais
ils veulent aussi à s'attarder sur ce
qui a pu pousser certaines personnes à
participer donc à cette attaque contre
le capitole le 6 janvier dernier une
attaque que nancy pelosi la chef de file
des démocrates à la chambre des
représentants qualifie d' attaque contre
notre démocratie
écoutez la tonalité du côté des élus
démocrates
il est de notre responsabilité
collective d'utiliser l'autorité qui
nous est donnée pour sélectionner un
panel de personnes dévouées à lenquête à
ses causes et à l'attack pas seulement
les assaillants mais aussi les
conspirateurs et les complices si vous
ne pouvez pas protéger la maison du
peuple que dieu vous aide à protéger
celle de votre famille que l'ancien
président soit pillé il faut se souvenir
qu'à la fin du mois de mai dernier les
républicains s'étaient opposés à la
formation d'une commission une
commission bipartisane qui avait été
imaginé sur le même modèle que celle qui
avait suivi les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 ce que les républicains
reprochent aux démocrates en réalité
c'est qu'ils aient un billet qu'ils
soient dans une approche trop partisane
pour les enquêtes concernant donc cette
attaque du capitole écoutez là encore la
tonalité de l'autre côté du côté des
républicains cette fois les événements
du 6 janvier ont été tragiques à bien
des égards et exige certainement une
véritable enquête mais des enquêtes
bipartite ont déjà eu lieu au sénat et
les forces de l'ordre continuent
également enquêté nous partageons tous
la préoccupation pour ce qui s'est passé
ici à washington district ce jour là et
ça ne doit plus jamais se reproduire
mais à moins que les démocrates
n'abandonne leur désir d'un résultat
couru d'avancé
nous ne rendons pas service au peuple
américain aller de l'avant et faire en
sorte que cela ne se reproduise plus
nécessite une solution bi partite pas un
comité partisans un truc et dès le
départ cette résolution regorge de
politique partisane et c'est le pire
alors il faut quand même noter que lors
du vote pour la formation de cette
commission spéciale il y a deux élus
républicains qui ont voté pour
d'ailleurs l'une d'entre elles une des
élues républicaines en question va
participer à cette commission elle va
siéger c'est ce qu'a annoncé nancy
pelosi dans le courant de la journée
aujourd'hui ce sont deux élus
républicains qui s'était déjà
relativement éloigné de la ligne du
parti puisqu'il avait déjà exprimé un
certain nombre de critiques contre
donald trump et des sanctions pourraient
être attendus notamment maintenant de la
part des chefs du parti républicain
alors concernant cette commission
concrètement à quoi elle va servir elle
bien elle va déjà pouvoir assigner les
témoins convoqués donc des témoins
également demandé l'accès à un certain
nombre de documents je vous dire qu'il
est encore un certain nombre de zones
d'ombré sur ce qu'il s'est déroulé donc
le 6 janvier dernier avec notamment
quelles informations possédait les
services de renseignement et la police
du capitole
on a l'impression au départ on a dit
beaucoup que elle est la plus du
capitole avait été débordé mais il
semblerait que finalement il y avait
quelques indices ici ou là de
d'agissements potentiel de la part d'un
certain nombre d'individus peut être
alors que la réponse de la police n'a
pas été suffisante c'est justement une
des zones d'ombré que va devoir
éclaircir cette commission spéciale
évidemment cette commission elle est
très politique malgré tout on se
rappelle que joe biden avait parlé de l'
attaque contre le capitole comme de la
pire attaque contre la démocratie
américaine depuis la guerre civile ça
avait beaucoup provoqué beaucoup de
critiques ici on se rappelle aussi que
cette attaque contre le capitole avait
conduit à une procédure d' impeachment
contre donald trump une procédure qui
n'avait pas abouti parce que le sénat à
majorité républicaine s'y étaient
opposés mais en tout cas ce qui est
important de noter enfin pour
hier c'est qu' il n'y a pas de deadline
n'y a pas d'agenda pour cette commission
spéciale ça veut dire qu'elle va pouvoir
travailler pendant plusieurs mois
peut-être même jusqu'à l'année prochaine
et vous avez déjà des élus républicains
républicain qui commencent à dire que
peut-être cette commission spéciale va
pouvoir servir aux démocrates dans le
cadre de la campagne des élections de mi
mandat qui auront lieu l'année prochaine
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et le